What are the most popular
things folks design on Canva?
The range of things people design
on Canva is pretty astronomical.
Presentations are really popular.
We've had 1 billion
presentations created recently.
Everything from social media graphics
to marketing materials,
videos, print products,
the whole suite of products that people
have now created
15 billion designs with.
200 new designs every
second. Is that right?
I think that’s correct, yeah.
Pretty crazy.
Hi Melanie. Thank you
so much for doing this.
So good to be here with you.
How's the weather in Sydney?
It's been really lovely.
We've had some really lovely
sunny weather for our winter.
Why did you start Canva?
Many years ago I was at university
and I was teaching design programs
and I thought they were
extraordinarily complicated.
It would take a whole semester for
people to learn the very basics,
and so I believed in the future
everything would be
online and collaborative
and really simple.
And we've been really working
towards that now for the last decade.
By we you mean
you and your co-founders
and one of your co-founders I believe
became your future husband, right?
Yeah, well, he was actually my boyfriend
before he became my co-founder, Cliff.
It is quite funny looking back because
obviously over the last decade I've had
to learn about venture capital and angel
investors and just the whole vocabulary
and the whole world.
But at that point in time, we're just like,
let's create some software.
Flash forward 10 years and Canva has
been valued as high as $40 billion,
making it one of the world's most
valuable private software companies,
but continuing to grow
and compete with companies
like Adobe and Microsoft
will be no small task.
And unlike other tech giants,
this software company is a
ways away from Silicon Valley.
The company's based in Sydney.
Is that an advantage or a disadvantage?
I think it's a massive advantage.
So a vast majority of our product
work is done in Australia.
We have been in
a very fortunate position
that we've been profitable
for the last six years.
We've got 3,900 people in our team.
We've been continuing to grow our
team, so we've become very global.
So we're in 85% of Fortune 500's
from the HR department to the people
team to marketing and sales.
As I understand it, you have
a dedicated Head of Vibes?
We do.
And you've got a 70 person team
focused on just creating a vibe.
Tell me about this.
Correct.
I guess when we started out,
we always wanted to create a
company that we wanted to work at.
In the early days, Cliff
would make lunch for everyone,
and we've just kept that rolling.
And so now we've got
almost 4,000 people
and obviously Cliff can't
make lunch for everyone.
So we've got 70 amazing
people in our Vibe team
who they help create celebrations and
they help create team bonding events
and they help create
the office environment
and vibe to keep everyone together
and feeling great.
Do you think of Canva as an antidote
to the sort of stereotypical tech bro
culture of Silicon Valley?
I dunno. I've just always
focused on doing it our way,
doing it the way that makes sense for us.
If that's an antidote,
I mean, so be it.
Let's talk about AI.
What is Canva's AI strategy?
The whole premise of Canva
was to make design simpler
and easier for everyone.
That was the genesis,
and we're in a really fortunate position
that AI just really accelerates that.
And so we have been
deeply embedding AI
across the entirety of our visual suite.
So inside our products, you can
now use generative AI to create content.
You can edit a photo
and add something in.
Do you want me to show you?
Yeah.
Let's do it. OK,
I'll share you this link so
we can collaborate together
and then I'll show you
some magic features.
It pops up all these different
templates that you can choose from.
Should we do a presentation
on AI and software?
AI and software?
Wow. That was fast.
And then you can come here and you
can replace anything that you like.
Let's get a picture of San Francisco
and you can just drag and drop
and place it onto your page.
There we go.
Beautiful.
What would you like in the water?
Dolphins.
Oh, dolphins. Yeah, let's do that.
Wow, that's crazy. Cool.
When Canva first came onto the scene,
it had an immediate edge
over software giants
by appealing to more casual users.
But now Adobe,
longtime, a top seller
of creative software
has had time to catch up
with competing user-friendly tools,
plans to buy Figma,
a global web design platform,
and its investments in generative AI.
What makes you think
you can beat them?
I think there was a
huge gap in the market,
and so it's not necessarily competing,
but creating something that filled a
gap that people really experienced.
You sort of have Microsoft
on one side, which was very
not necessarily very beautiful,
and then you'd have
Adobe on the other side.
That was very complicated,
and we saw this gap in the middle
where people wanted to design something really great
to express their concepts
and to achieve their goals,
but they didn't necessarily have years
to invest in learning the tools.
And then with Canva,
obviously we've just done
use this same platform,
so you can design each of these
different things with the same ease.
So you can design a presentation as
easily as you can design a website.
I think something that we're really
excited about is combining all of these
different aspects together,
and we think that we are
in a great position to help
do this dance where we take
technology and we take creativity and
we combine them together.
Because AI does a
great job at some things,
but not other things.
Like creating a really authentic image
is something that AI
does not do a great job of.
So combining them together
to help people achieve their goals
is very much where we're focused
and we're extraordinarily
excited to create the magic
over the next decade.
Well, here's to try and make
more magic. We'll be watching.
Thank you so much, Emily.
Lovely to chat with you.